“Este es un gran lugar para trabajar”
Esto es lo que dijo Donald Trump refiriéndose
a la Casa Blanca a principios de marzo de
2018, horas antes de hacerse pública la dimisión
de su principal asesor económico, Gary Cohn.
En cualquier otro momento esta frase no hubiese
tenido nada de particular, no hubiese llamado
la atención absolutamente de nadie.
Al fin y al cabo, la Casa Blanca, y no creo
que sea algo que sorprenda a nadie, es uno
de los lugares más cotizados del mundo para
trabajar. Tener un empleo en el equipo del
presidente supone poder, influencia y reconocimiento.
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
nos estamos olvidando de algo, de un detalle
muy importante:
de quién es el presidente de Estados Unidos
y de cómo es su particular carácter. Lo
sabéis bien, amigos, en el diccionario Trump,
el término “habitual”… no tiene cabida,
no existe.
¿No me creeis? Pues atentos.
(TURBULENCIAS EN EL ALA OESTE)
En enero de 2017 juraron su cargo las 23 personas
más importantes del Ala Oeste de la Casa Blanca.
Es decir, las personas que compondrían
el equipo más cercano al presidente: el jefe
de gabinete, el secretario de prensa, el consejero
de seguridad nacional, el director de comunicaciones,
etcétera, etcétera.
Es decir, todas esas personas que solemos
ver en las series y en las películas al lado
del presidente.
Claro que.. amigos, Donald no es Josiah Bartlet
y sobrevivir en su administración empieza
a ser más difícil que montar un negocio
en la Venezuela de Nicolás Maduro.
[Un momento… ¿No sabéis quien es Josiah
Bartlet? ¿No habéis visto The West Wing,
El Ala Oeste de la Casa Blanca? Pues si es
así, no perdáis ni un minuto, es una serie
muy pero que muy recomendable si te gusta
la política]
Pero… no nos desviemos, regresemos a la
Casa Blanca de Donald Trump.
¿Sabeis cuantas de estas 23 personas que
formaban la guardia pretoriana del presidente
cuando comenzó este su mandato, continúan
hoy en el cargo? Pues… de 23… apenas continuan
9… y alguno de estos 9 está en la cuerda
floja.
Pero, puede que estés pensado… bueno…
parece que se equivocó al elegir… oye un
error… lo tiene cualquiera… Pues… el
problema es que ahí no termina todo.
Kathryn Dunn Tenpas, una investigadora del
Brookings Institute, uno de los más importantes
Think Tanks de Washington, está siguiendo
minuciosamente los cambios que se están produciendo
prácticamente todas las semanas en la Oficina
Ejecutiva del Presidente, en el Ala Oeste
de la Casa Blanca.
Pues bien, si tenemos en cuenta a los 23 fichajes
que juraron su cargo en enero de 2017, a los
cargos que fueron nombrados después, a las
que han sido sustituidas cesados o han dimitido
y a las personas que trabajan para ellos,
en total, han formado parte de la Oficina
del Presidente hasta este momento 65 personas
Pues bien, la tasa de rotación es ya del
48%.
Es decir, para que nos entendamos, en poco
más de un año, la mitad de quienes han formado
el equipo ya no están en su puesto.
Una tasa de rotación tan elevada que no tiene
precedentes:
los escándalos, los desencuentros con el
presidente o, simplemente, los cambios de
humor del inquilino del Despacho Oval han
hecho, amigos, que trabajar hoy en
el Ala Oeste sea una profesión de alto riesgo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, los despidos,
las dimisiones y los cambios se están sucediendo
a una velocidad 3 veces mayor que la de la
Administración Obama y 2 veces la de Reagan,
que hasta ahora tenía el récord.
[De verdad, ¡Está siendo una locura! En
poco más de un año, y atentos porque no
estamos hablando precisamente de puestos menores,
Trump ha tenido 2 secretarios de prensa,
2 Jefes de Gabinete, 2 asesores de Seguridad
Nacional y 5 personas diferentes han sido
nombradas como Director de comunicaciones.
En este tiempo Donald Trump ha despedido incluso
a sus abogados]
Y lo que es peor… según las informaciones
disponibles todo apunta a que las cosas van
a ir aún a peor.
Por ejemplo, se da por hecho el próximo despido
del actual Asesor de Seguridad Nacional, el
General McMaster e incluso también de John
Kelly, su actual Jefe de Gabinete.
“Trump decide despedir a su Asesor de Seguridad
Nacional”
Donald Trump les escogió, pero parece que
luego no le han caído del todo bien…
Así que, amigos, con este panorama ya podemos
entender por qué muchos miembros de su equipo,
según han confesado, se pasan gran parte
del tiempo tratando de no provocar a un presidente
que se enfada muy, pero que muy fácilmente.
[¿Os imagináis a Trump recorriendo los pasillos
de la Casa Blanca, diciendo despedido, despedido…
pues… parece que la realidad no es muy distinta.
Sí, parece que Trump se tomó muy enserio
su puesto en el Aprendiz, el popular programa
de TV donde básicamente despedía  a la gente.
“Es devastador. Ningún negocio podría
manejar algo así, mucho menos el gobierno.
Se supone que se necesita continuidad y estabilidad,
pero eso no está en su léxico”. William
M. Daley, Jefe de Gabinete con Barack Obama.
Pero vale, puede que os estéis preguntado…
pero ¿Qué está pasando? ¿Cuáles pueden
ser los motivos para tantos cambios?
Pues, la verdad, los hay de todos los
tipos y colores…
Algunos se han tenido que marchar forzados
por los escándalos, como el consejero de
Seguridad Nacional, Michael T. Flynn o el
secretario de personal Rob Porter, acusado
de malos tratos.
Este fue también el caso de Bannon….
Hasta el mes de agosto de 2017 fue la mano
derecha del Donald Trump en su carrera política,
pero ni siquiera eso le salvó. Conocido por sus
posiciones muy nacionalistas, Steve Bannon
había sido nombrado Consejero del Presidente
y Jefe de Estrategia de la Casa Blanca. Pues
bien, pasados poco más de 6 meses, Trump decidió
echarle. Al final, Bannon se adelantó y presentó
una dimisión forzada.
Otros, como el asesor económico y ex directivo
de Goldman Sachs, Gary Cohn o el Secretario
de Prensa, Sean Spicer, se han marchado por
sus discrepancias con el presidente.
Y otros han sido directamente despedidos:
“El asistente personal de Trump, John McEntee,
despedido por un problema de seguridad"
Luego tenemos, casos como, por ejemplo, el
de Omarosa Manigault, hasta diciembre de 2017
Asistente del presidente y Directora de Comunicaciones
de la Oficina de Enlace Público.
Veréis, Omarosa era básicamente conocida
por participar en realities de televisión,
en uno de los cuales, en el Aprendiz conoció
a Donald Trump y gracias a ello pasó a formar
parte del equipo del presidente cuando éste
llegó a la Casa Blanca.
Pues bien, en diciembre de 2017 “dimitió”
de forma repentina alegando que había visto
cosas muy raras que le habían hecho sentir
muy incomoda y le habían afectado emocionalmente.
¿Sabéis cuál fue su siguiente paso después
de dimitir?
Pues… ni más ni menos que entrar en Gran
Hermano VIP donde se ha dedicado a airear
trapos sucios del surrealismo diario que vivía
como empleada de la Casa Blanca.
Menudo ojo tiene Trump para fichar… y eso
que siempre ha presumido de que ese era uno
de sus fuertes… elegir a las personas que
le acompañan y trabajan para él.
¡Menos mal!
Pero… vale, puede que alguno de vosotros
esté pensado… sí, Alberto, lo de su equipo
en el Ala Oeste se ha ido un poco de madre…
pero el gobierno, es decir, a nivel de secretarios
- lo que en otros lugares conocemos como Ministros
- la cosa seguro que es diferente.
Pues… me parece que no mucho… atentos.
EL GABINETE
El gabinete, el órgano que está formado
por los principales cargos del Gobierno de
los Estados Unidos tampoco se salva del terremoto
Trump.
Veréis, en junio de 2017 se celebró la primera
reunión con todo el gabinete al completo,
Trump declaró públicamente que había reunido
a un grupo extraordinario de talentos” para
formar su gobierno.
Pues bien, desde entonces, amigos, lo menos
que podemos decir, es que las cosas han cambiado.
Desde entonces se han producido 5 rotaciones
en el gabinete, que son más que todas las
que tuvo George Bush en sus dos mandatos y
más de la mitad de las de Obama ¡todo en un solo año!
De estos 5 cambios, por cierto, 3 han sido
despidos o “dimisiones” fulminantes:
Las de Reince Priebus, Tom Price y la más
surrealista de todas, la última, la de Rex
Tillerson, Secretario de Estado y previamente poderoso
CEO de la Exxon Mobbil, la mayor petrolera
de los Estados Unidos.
Rex Tillerson, amigos, fue despedido por Twitter!!!
Sin que Trump se lo comunicará ni siquiera
personalmente.
De hecho, según se cuenta, John Kelly, el
Jefe de Gabinete de Trump llamó a Tillerson
que se encontraba en plena gira por África,
para decirle
que el Presidente le iba a echar, que regresará
a Washington y que se planteara dimitir.
No está claro si al final no quiso, no se
lo creyó o no le dió tiempo, pero el caso
es que Trump le fulminó por Twitter
Ahora las apuestas sobre quiénes serán los
próximos candidatos en esta de particular
diana de Donald Trump, crecen como la espuma.
Ben Carson, Secretario de Vivienda, David
Shulkin, Secretario de asuntos veteranos,
Ryan Zinke, Secretario de Interior, Scott
Pruitt, director de la Agencia de Protección
del Medio Ambiente y el poderoso Jeff Sessions,
el fiscal general, copan todas las apuestas,
son los grandes favoritos para ser los siguientes
en ser despedidos.
Por cierto, a este último, a Jeff Sessions,
Trump le culpa de no haber parado las investigaciones
sobre el tema de la injerencia rusa en las
elecciones presidenciales que le llevaron
a la Casa Blanca.
Trump está harto. Él es el presidente así
que él y sólo él es el que manda. ¿Qué
se han pensado? ¿Qué es eso de que responsables
del FBI o del Departamento de Justicia quieran
investigarlo? ¿Cómo se atreven? ¿independencia?
De eso nada.
Y, ojo, amigos, porque Trump no se ha cortado
ni un pelo. Por este motivo ha despedido a
responsables del FBI como James Comey o Andrew
McCabe.
Y por el mismo motivo también ha señalado
a Robert Mueller, el fiscal especial que investiga
la injerencia de Rusia en las elecciones,
como el próximo en ser despedido.
Algo que ha hecho, atentos, que todo un senador
republicano, Jeff Flake, senador por Arizona,
advierta públicamente al Presidente sobre
su posible destitución. Tal cual como lo
escucháis.
"Le rogamos al presidente que no despida al
fiscal especial. Que no cree una crisis constitucional.
El Congreso no puede evitar ese despido. Nuestro
único remedio constitucional sería a posteriori,
mediante el 'impeachment”
Pues bien amigos, estos son los motivos por
los que trabajar en la Administración Trump
es algo cada vez menos atractivo, incluso
para los republicanos.
“No hay un gran apetito entre los republicanos
por explorar las oportunidades de trabajo
en esta administración. Ryan Williams, exportavoz
de Mitt Romney.
[Por cierto ¿habéis caído en una de las principales
consecuencias que esto tiene?.
¿Quién va a querer trabajar en esta administración?
Pensadlo un momento, si tuvieses un buen trabajo,
un buen puesto, ¿lo arriesgarías todo? ¿Vuestra
reputación, vuestra carrera profesional para
trabajar en una administración como esta,
donde te pueden despedir mañana con un tweet?
Estoy convencido que en muchos casos la respuesta
sería NO.
Así que una consecuencia muy posible es que
la Administración Trump termine funcionando
como una especie de aspiradora, nutriéndose
no precisamente con los mejores perfiles]
En fin, amigos, así están las cosas por
Washington… ¡Y eso que Trump solo lleva
un año en la Casa Blanca! ¿Te ha gustado
este vídeo? Si es así, dale al botón de
like y ayúdanos compartiéndolo con tus amigos.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!